the health district says if you travel
for spring break or easter you should
think about getting tested for covet 19.
as more and more people get vaccinated
testing numbers have
gone down significantly over the past
month hector mejia live at allegiant
stadium where a pop-up testing site
opens here in just a few hours hey
hector
[Music]
hey there alex good morning and this is
a pretty big deal i mean this is an
nfl stadium we're talking about and it's
your chance to check out
allegiant stadium the home of the
raiders at least from the outside where
right now you can see the sunshine and
a pretty nice view from the parking lots
things are quiet now but in just a few
hours these massive parking lots will
turn into a drive-through testing site
it's happening today only here at
allegion stadium from 8 in the morning
to
one in the afternoon in lot h the
entrance is just off dean martin drive
and it's faster if you pre-register
that's an option so you can head over to
the health district's website
right now officials hope that today's
drive through event is a one-stop shop
for the entire family to get screened
we just had spring break and easter
celebrations
if you're not fully vaccinated that's
two weeks after your last required dose
and you traveled
the cdc recommends to self-quarantine
for seven days even with a negative test
if you don't get tested you're asked to
quarantine at least 10 days
only fully vaccinated domestic travelers
are no longer required to get tested or
to self quarantine
many of the valley's biggest testing
sites like cashman center and unlv have
converted to vaccine centers
while local health officials say that is
great we still need to spot those who
are infected
to prevent others from getting sick so
we'll be here throughout the morning as
that testing
gets underway we're actually getting a
preview at around 7 30 this morning
we'll have that live for you on facebook
live and also throughout the day and
later on at noon for now reporting live
hector mejia
8 news now back to you guys